to another jury in minneapolis that's
deciding the fate of former police
officer kim park kim potter the jury got
the case after emotional testimony from
potter who broke down on the stand while
insisting she did not intend to hurt
anyone potter is on trial for shooting
and killing 20-year-old dante wright
during a traffic stop in april david
schuman of our minneapolis station wcco
tv is covering the trial
i'm sorry it happened
former brooklyn center police officer
kim potter took the stand in her own
defense last week her first public
comments on the shooting that killed
20-year-old dante wright in april
police pulled right over for hanging an
air freshener from his rear view mirror
which is illegal in minnesota before
discovering he had a warrant
during an attempted arrest body cam
video shows potter drawing her gun and
shouting taser
before shooting right in the chest
remember yelling taser taser taser
and nothing happened
and then
he told me
in closing arguments monday the defense
said wright's attempt to flee in his car
put a fellow officer in danger
and that potter's actions while tragic
were justified not to write causes own
death unfortunately and the walk of life
nobody's perfect
everybody makes mistakes and this lady
here
made a mistake and my gosh
a mistake is not a crime it just isn't
but prosecutor aaron eldridge disagreed
and said potter violated years of
training by drawing and then using the
wrong weapon an accidental killing
is still a crime
if the defendant's actions are reckless
it was a tragedy of her own making
and it's not just a tragedy
it's manslaughter for cbs mornings i'm
david schuman in minneapolis minnesota